[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Nicolas Chris Martin bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste sportif on vous lit
notamment dans SoFoot et vous signez ce
livre manifeste qui sort la semaine
prochaine je crois aux éditions
Libertalia son titre et sans équivoque
Qatar le Mondial de la honte le Mondial
c'est dans un mois tout juste le 20
novembre prochain coup d'envoi de la
compétition à Doha à 17h heure locale je
crois par un Qatar Équateur une honte
donc je suis pas le premier à le dire
donc et contrairement à ce qu'on peut
entendre en ce moment ça fait longtemps
que différentes personnalités ONG
syndicats évoque forcément employé ce
verbe enfin ce mot une situation qui est
inacceptable je rappelle donc la
question des droits des travailleurs la
question du nombre de morts
chantier qui est devenu les Mira mais il
y a aussi la question écologique la
question évidemment des droits des
femmes des droits LGBT ça fait beaucoup
plus en plus le fonctionnement très
particulier de la FIFA autour ou du
monde voilà on sait que par exemple j'ai
un enfantino le président de la FIFA et
aujourd'hui un résident du Qatar ce qui
même par rapport à cette institution qui
n'était pourtant pas très regardante par
le passé et tout à fait nouveau voir
exceptionnel alors on va détailler tout
ce que vous venez de dire dans un
instant mais avant d'aller plus loin
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler pourquoi et
dans quelles circonstance c'est le cata
qui a été désigné peyote il y a une
dizaine d'années alors tout le monde
explique que c'est une surprise mais
lors de son attribution donc il y a une
dizaine d'années par la FIFA c'était une
récompense c'est à dire que il y avait
un mélange d'intérêt d'un côté le fait
que Qatar était devenu un acteur
économique incontournable du football
c'est pour ça quand on parle de
corruption il y en a peut-être eu à la
marge un petit peu d'ailleurs on voit
même qu'au Japon autour des des JO il y
a un responsable japonais qui vient
d'être inculpé mais c'est vraiment le
fait que ce pays s'était Mira à travers
ses investissements massifs dans les
médias et dans les clubs sportifs et
dans le football en général était devenu
incontournable d'autre part il y avait
cette volonté entre guillemets au nom de
l'universalisme de football de tenir une
coupe du monde dans un pays arabe mais
étrangement
d'autres nations comme par exemple le
Maroc quoi qu'on pense du régime était
quand même mieux placé grand pays de
foot des grands clubs une passion
populaire une infrastructure touristique
tout semblait le désigner donc pourquoi
le Qatar a eu la Coupe du Monde il l'a
acheté simplement mais il a acheté non
pas un par corruption mais parce qu'il
est devenu un acteur économique
important depuis c'est un chemin de
croix pour la FIFA qui doit passer son
temps à justifier à expliquer son choix
pour le Qatar qui essaye de contrer le
fait qu'il existe malgré tout des
esprits critiques et des gens qui ont
travaillé sur le sujet et par ailleurs
le football a vécu une série de
dévolution on a déplacé à coupe du monde
au mois de novembre et aujourd'hui par
exemple vous avez énormément de joueurs
qui sont blessés et qui ne pourront pas
y participer parce que c'est pas la
bonne période c'était lié au fait que il
faisait beaucoup trop chaud en été au
Qatar même avec la climatisation en plus
ça donne une image assez problématique
où ça a mis les footballeurs les
institutions et fédérations sont assez
lettres et même les fans de football qui
commencent à se poser des questions par
s'ils vont regarder ou pas donc voilà
alors l'événement effectivement qui est
d'ordinaire l'un des plus regardés de la
planète un Gallio tous les quatre ans et
donc auréolé vous l'avez rappelé qui est
deux soupçons de corruption d'accusation
de trafic d'êtres humains en 6500 morts
sur les chantiers des stades de foot non
respect des droits de l'homme et des
femmes d'aberration écologiques mais
plus d'un million de supporters tout de
même sont attendus au Qatar pour les
matchs et aucune sélection n'a
véritablement envisagé réellement de
boycotter l'événement c'est pour ça que
moi personnellement j'ai jamais défendu
l'idée d'un boycott parce que la notion
boycott il faut savoir de quoi on parle
c'est pas le boycott individuel si vous
décidez pas regarder la Coupe du monde
après tout c'est votre liberté citoyens
ou citoyenne non jamais aucun État
n'aurait boycoté cette Coupe du Monde
d'abord la France n'aurait ne pouvait
pas le faire d'abord et d'ailleurs
essentiel dans l'attribution de la Coupe
du Monde
Qatar et parce que c'est Qatar est un
pays reconnu internationalement avec qui
tout le monde fait du business je voyais
mal les fédérations les footballeurs de
boycotter non non c'est tout le monde va
y aller il y aura sûrement beaucoup de
supporters qui vont se déplacer vous
savez le monde il y a un monde sans
Occident c'est-à-dire que nous on a des
préoccupations mais par exemple pour
beaucoup de pays c'est très secondaire
c'est comme la guerre en Ukraine qui
part dans 1000 lointaine et qui est un
imprime personnel nous quand on vient
poser ces questions parfois ça peut
sembler très euh
occidental au centre de dire de de de
juste que les gens dont on parle qui
sont exploités qui sont des Népalais des
Indiens par ailleurs de pays ou de
football n'a pas une très grande
importance mais qui sont donc c'est en
défendant d'abord ces personnes là mais
il y a cette notion que ben on va quand
même en profiter il y a beaucoup de
suite américain qui sont attendus moins
d'America apparemment mais il y a eu des
Chinois et cetera la question qui se
pose d'ailleurs avec cette affût de
personnes c'est que pour information le
Qatar a été obligé entre guillemets de
s'entendre avec l'Arabie Saoudite son
voisin avec qui était quasiment au bord
de la guerre il y a pas si longtemps
pour ouvrir des frontières pour que les
les touristes et les supporters puissent
aller dormir dans les hôtels en Arabie
Saoudite c'est vous dire si même la même
la cata avec tout l'argent qu'il a
dépensé on parle de 200 milliards de
budget n'est pas forcément capacité
d'accueillir une coupe du monde de
football alors vous dites que le boycott
populaire n'a pas forcément de sens ou
en tout cas d'efficacité pour autant il
y a un vrai cas de conscience qui se
pose à beaucoup d'amoureux du football
dont vous êtes est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
se dire peut-être que si le mondial en
terme d'audience fait alors peut-être
pas un flop mais moins que les éditions
précédentes ça pourrait peut-être
pousser les organisateurs les
distributeurs à se remettre en question
je précise je pense juste que le bacon
diplomatique ou des états n'auraient
jamais eu les boycottes populaires c'est
une vraie question au sens où
effectivement le football est un
phénomène social très important qui a un
impact au-delà simplement de des
passionnés il faut rappeler quand même
qu'une prison de la République a pris le
téléphone pour convaincre Mbappé de
rester au PSG donc c'est pas rien comme
phénomène en France oui le populaire
c'est les audiences sont en berne sont
moins bonnes il faut savoir que la FIFA
vit et se nourrit des droits télé et du
marketing donc ça pourrait avoir un
impact maintenant il faudrait vraiment
qu'il soit massif c'est à dire qu'il y
ait 10% ou 20% voir 50% en moins pour
que ça commence à gratter un peu le
cerveau des classiques de cette belle
institution située en Suisse avec le
statut d'organisation
à butatives qui à mourir de rire et
d'ailleurs s'ils sont en Suisse ça doit
être pour le climat je suppose mais
voilà donc non il faudrait vraiment
qu'il y ait quelque chose de massif et
au niveau mondial parce qu'aujourd'hui
la FIFA elle regarde les droits télé
internationaux même s'il est plus riches
et les plus gros se situent
effectivement en Europe et aux
États-Unis à ce niveau là j'y crois
moyennement mais après il y a un vrai
trouble et c'est vrai que pour la FIFA
c'est une vraie question parce que le
raccord et le regard au football à
travers ses Coupe du monde surtout si
tout n'est pas idyllique notamment en
terme d'organisation va forcément les
incliner à changer on parle déjà d'un
après cathare autour de ces questions là
de prendre en compte de nouvelles crites
de nouveaux critères l'attribution des
précédents alors ça n'a rien à voir avec
la Coupe du monde de football mais je
pense à la super ligne qui a été
extraordinairement critiquée et
finalement alors c'est pas la pression
populaire qui a fait reculer les clubs
c'était l'idée d'organiser une super
coupe européenne privée
a pas disparu du tout mais disons que la
pression la pression a fait des
supporters et des états malgré tout
plusieurs grandes villes françaises et
pas des moindres à Paris Lille Marseille
ont décidé de ne pas organiser pour
cette Coupe du Monde de Fan Zone pas de
retransmission des matchs est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas se dire que c'est aussi
privé des gens dans une période un peu
triste un peu compliqué aussi d'une
belle fête populaire qui reste alors pas
pour tous les matchs mais gratuite
est-ce que ça c'est pas dommage
c'est vaste question d'abord il y a un
petit côté bonne conscience de dernière
minute que moi je veux pas nier parce
que notamment venant de ville comme
Paris où il y a de Paris Saint-Germain
et que voilà donc c'est la propriété
c'est un peu facile de le faire de
décider ça maintenant par ailleurs pour
beaucoup de ces villes c'est aussi un
bel argument pour expliquer qu'on fera
pas sûrement de grand écran et beaucoup
de villes l'ont fait pour des raisons
économiques c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer parce qu'il y a la crise
écarine énergétique et ça coûte très
cher des grands écrans et des fans zone
par c'est en novembre décembre donc
forcément moins de monde parce qu'il
aurait fait froid on privilégié pas
grand chose les matchs de l'équipe de
France par la loi sont diffusés
gratuitement il y en a de moins en moins
dans les coupes du monde c'est peut-être
un vrai combat amener par ailleurs pour
ceux qui s'insurgent contre des
décisions de ces villes il y avait
peut-être d'autres choses à faire plutôt
pour sensibiliser les personnes à cette
question par exemple il y a des communes
comme un Bagneux qui ont décidé de
laisser des jeunes ils ont pas les
moyens de faire un écran genre mais
utiliser des salles éventuellement de
fait mais du moment qu'il y avait une
introduction quelqu'un qui intervenait
pour situer le contexte voilà il de
Fania mais c'est vraiment pour moi un
micro débat cette histoire des écrans
géants ça suscite beaucoup d'indignation
beaucoup de réactions c'est peut-être le
but après tout mais l'essentiel n'est
pas là vous vous écrivez dans votre
manifeste que si Kylian Mbappe marque en
finale il effectuera son exploit sur un
cimetière on l'a dit vous évoquez entre
autres les ouvriers sur les chantiers
est-ce qu'on en demande pas trop au
joueur
non non pas trop je j'ai une fois encore
qui Mbappé par ailleurs est un cas de
figure c'est-à-dire qu'il s'est quand
même beaucoup engagé il a pris des
positions fortes sur certains sujets de
société on voit bien qu'il est très
silencieux sur celui-là on comprend
pourquoi son patron c'est le Paris
Saint-Germain et QSI maintenant mais
peut-être qu'il va commencer à parler vu
les relations qu'il est en train
d'entretenir est-ce qu'il a appris sur
eux mais effectivement on peut attendre
de footballeur notamment qui ont pris
des positions comme sur la question des
ouigo en Chine c'est le cas de Griezmann
de de au moins s'exprimer une fois
encore moi je leur demande pas de
boycotter je fais pas poser sur les
footballeurs c'est la décision était de
l'État parce que l'État a une tutelle
sera Fédération Française de Football
d'ailleurs à quoi c'est toujours réfugié
une nouvelle de great et c'était à
l'État au gouvernement et éventuellement
aux oppositions d'interpeller le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée ce qui n'a
jamais été fait c'est à ce niveau-là que
ça s'est situé pour les footballeurs
malgré tout même si c'est pas sûr que ça
doit reposer au même titre que nous en
tant que téléspectateurs on a des
questions et des interrogations à se
poser eux ils seront là bas ils auront
une parole c'est ce que demande un
initiat internationale exprimez-vous
peser pour que par exemple la FFF tient
ses débuts le début petit début
d'engagement sur la question des fonds
d'indemnisation pour des familles des
personnes qui ont décédées lors de la
construction des stades et des
infrastructures en général alors ici en
France vous l'avez invoqué il faut
cette attribution de la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar nous concerne en premier lieu
elle est une affaire d'état dit certains
allaient en tout cas une affaire de
justice dans laquelle on croit dans
laquelle on croise des anciens
présidents des stars du ballon rond des
hommes d'affaires la question étant la
France a-t-elle aider le Qatar a obtenir
ce Mondial et si oui en échange de quoi
évidemment et en fait une fois encore je
voudrais qu'on sorte de cette histoire
de corruption c'est c'est les relations
classiques au niveau de ce qui est
capitaliste classique c'est-à-dire le
Qatar est un investisseur massif
aujourd'hui parce qu'il a compris qu'il
y aurait un après-gaz naturel c'est pas
source de richesse et qui essaye de
transformer cette richesse en un moyen
de pouvoir en investissant aujourd'hui
par exemple en France dans le sport ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs pas uniquement dans
le sport il a il y a un prix dès qu'il y
a un prix il y a un prix hippique qui
revient il a il avait par exemple il
loue les seuil de la marine pour très
cher pour mettre c'est une sa collection
de cannelle voter de rayonnement oui la
France a contribué fortement parce que
Nicolas Sarko il le reconnaît encore
aujourd'hui il le dit très clairement
qu'il s'est battu pour que le Qatar et
la Coupe du Monde il a été jusqu'à
convaincre Michel Platini changer d'avis
parce que au départ tout le monde le
savait il était plutôt pour la
candidature des États-Unis qui pose
aussi des problèmes et et donc la France
oui a joué un rôle et les entreprises
françaises BTP ou autre parce que aller
sur internet Google il est français au
Qatar vous verrez que beaucoup de gens
se sont mis à bosser là-bas
a reçu en retour beaucoup de commandes
de contrats c'est un partenaire
économique très important de la France
la fameuse histoire des rafales donc
tout le monde a parlé mais qui est
secondaire qui s'est tendu sur deux
quinquennat y compris François Hollande
qui n'a pas de ce point de vue là malgré
ses quatre conscience aujourd'hui
changer grand chose dans la position du
pays voilà donc lui la France a
contribué en échange de relation
économique diplomatique apaiser et
plutôt très bonne avec le Qatar on
rappelle que le Qatar est par ailleurs
un interlocuteur diplomatique dans la
région très importante notamment avec
l'Iran
pendant ce temps on parle pas beaucoup
de football Nicolas axis Martov
qu'est-ce que plus globalement tout ce
qui se joue autour de ce Mondial au
Qatar dit du football en général tout
dépend de football on parle le football
il reste toujours un des sports les plus
pratiqués dans le monde je rappelle que
malgré tout il y a des zones comme le
lundi cricket mais bon et plus grand que
la FIFA dites-vous
d'abord la FIFA est né après la fonction
du football qui se joue d'ailleurs de
manière très différente il y a du foot
mix il y a du walking foot le foot en
marchant pour les personnes de la
certaine âge donc je vais bientôt
rejoindre et il y a le foot à 7 auto
arbitré dans des fédérations comme
l'avait fait j'étais où lui fenêtre donc
il y a une diversité de pratique du
football qui reste un phénomène culturel
important dans la dans la société qui
s'ouvre de plus en plus notamment aux
femmes ça c'est un premier aspect le
football tel qu'on vient de parler c'est
le football en tant que un élément
important de la vie économique sociale
et politique du monde aujourd'hui c'est
une réalité de sport n'est plus
secondaire ou même titre d'ailleurs que
la culture n'a jamais été et de ce qu'on
apprend qu'en fait à travers le Qatar
qui révèle quand même beaucoup de choses
on pourra plus se poser des questions
pour la Russie en 2018 même si c'était
pas beaucoup entendu sur la Russie cela
dit la coupe de ce football et ce
football là qui a suscité tous ces
problèmes au Qatar alors que par exemple
l'invasion l'annexion de la Crimée
n'était pas due au football donc mais il
y avait des questions à se poser sur
l'attribution en Russie est-ce que la
manière dont Poutine a utilisé le
football mais il faut encore ça explique
le football est devenu quelque chose
essentiel donc vous dites on ne parle
pas beaucoup mais quand on parle de
politique de société et d'économie et de
ce qui se passe au Qatar on parle
football de football c'est aussi ça
c'est un mastodonte économique et
politique aujourd'hui sinon les pays ne
se battraient pas pour pouvoir gagner
une Coupe du monde voilà coûte à chacun
se fera son avis vous regarderez les
matchs ou pas c'est un vrai question que
je me pose parce que par ailleurs j'ai
un petit garçon à la maison qui a bien
envie de les voir donc je suis vraiment
torturé vous avez un mois pour répondre
à la question Nicolas merci beaucoup
Qatar le Mondial de la honte donc chez
Libertalia ça sort la semaine prochaine